We've been following whether Republicans and
Trump abandon Matt Gates or get behind him.
And so far, the approach seems to be don't
say too much one way or the other, just kind
of try to wait it out.
And this is something I'm not praising this
as morally a good thing, but Republicans seem
much more shrewd in this way than Democrats.
They're not jumping all over themselves to
condemn Matt Gates.
They are sticking to a comment.
There's a political article about this by
Gary.
Find out.
They are sticking to a combination of strategies
that include saying these allegations.
Many of them were first reported by The New
York Times.
That makes me skeptical.
That's perfect for the media.
Skeptical right wing movement that Donald
Trump created with the meme of fake news,
say, listen, you know, we have to see what's
going on.
But when the source is The New York Times,
I'm skeptical.
That's perfect cover for modern 20, 21 Republicans
to say that.
Others are saying straight up, I believe it
is fake news.
So down in Florida, there is a Gulf Breeze
activist named Larry Hatsu who straight up
says, I believe this is nothing more than
fake news.
I don't believe anything coming from mainstream
media.
Matt Gates has denied it all, and that's good
enough for many of them.
Other Republicans aren't as dismissive, but
they are saying that the allegations are vague.
It's unclear what's true.
There's conflicting reports and basically
they're just kind of sitting out of it.
One such example is John Roberts, not the
Fox News reporter, but the chair of the Escambia
County Republican Party.
He says, I wouldn't condone anyone having
sex with someone who's underage, etc., but
so far I haven't heard anything concrete.
And he says that I don't trust anonymous sources
from The New York Times.
I don't know ultimately whether Republicans
will abandon Matt Gates in this sort of piggybacks
off of the earlier story that we talked about
regarding the news that Matt Gates asked Donald
Trump for a pardon.
Even that even now is Republicans are being
presented with that fact.
But listen, isn't the fact that Gates asked
Trump for a pardon, a red flag that makes
you believe the story may well be true?
They are still saying exactly what I predicted
they would say in the last segment.
If you know that with Joe Biden coming in
and with all these so-called Democrat bomb
throwers, they're going to go after people
who supported President Trump.
Why wouldn't you ask for a preemptive pardon
if you knew you were going to get sandbagged
with bogus political charges once your party
was out of power?
Wouldn't you try to protect yourself and those
around you by asking for a preemptive pardon?
So for every bullet point so far, there is
a defense that they are coming up with.
There is also the contingent that, without
focusing on any of the specifics, is just
saying this is an attempt to take out conservatives
in particular districts and try to replace
them with a.
You know, it's it's predictable, I don't think
there's too much to say about that.
It's sort of an UN it's an indefeasible claim
and we will just have to follow and see ultimately
who stands behind Matt Gates and who doesn't.
My prediction is that you are going to have
if indeed we learn more about the specifics
and it starts to look very ugly, Matt gets
even uglier than it already looks.
I think you'll see a split.
You'll see some on the side of on the Republican
side, people like Mitt Romney, although who
knows whether Mitt Romney specifically would
comment on this?
Who would simply say Matt Gates should resign?
And then you will see people more under the
umbrella of like the Marjorie Taylor Green
Law and Bobert types who will stick with him.
They'll say it's a political witch hunt and
the same type of stuff Trump said about every
investigation into the things he did during
his presidency as well.
Time will tell it's not looking particularly
good for Matt Gates.
We do have a poll up, the results of which
will soon be on our Instagram page asking
what do you believe will be the ultimate consequence
or outcome for Matthew Gates?
You can follow us on Instagram at David Pakman
show.